cadáveres de animales sobre tierra
totalmente seca de la tanga sequía que
atraviesa el condado equilify en Kenia
allí cultivar se ha vuelto un imposible
la última vez que cultivamos y obtuvimos
productos fue hace cinco años por eso
Estamos cortando árboles para hacer
carbón para alimentarnos
según la Cruz Roja el país está
experimentando un tercer año sin lluvias
y se estima que 3,1 millones de personas
están amenazadas por una grave escasez
de alimentos
hemos dependido mucho de la agricultura
ahora hace tanto tiempo que no llueve
eso se ha convertido en un gran desafío
y ahora no tenemos alimentos en resumen
estamos obteniendo alimentos Pero no es
lo que se necesitan no es una dieta
balanceada
la situación es especialmente
preocupante para los niños en este
centro asistencial día a día llegan en
estado de desnutrición
los informes e incluso la situación está
empeorando en el sentido en que
analizamos las cifras en términos de
niños desnutridos que recibimos en
nuestras instalaciones y esto podría
deberse a la inseguridad alimentaria
ocasionada por la situación de sequía
hay un repunte en las cifras en toda la
región del este de África 4,2 millones
de personas se enfrentan a una grave
inseguridad alimentaria
según la red humanitaria de tierras
áridas y semiáridas una situación que
podría empeorar en el marco del Día
Mundial de la Alimentación de 2022 la
FAO alertó que el mundo se está alejando
de sus esfuerzos por eliminar el hambre
según cifras de la ONU el número de
personas que padecen hambre en el mundo
aumentó hasta alcanzar los 828 millones
de personas en 2021 unos 46 millones más
que en 2020 y se prevé que casi 670
millones de personas el 8% de la
población mundial seguirán pasando
hambre en 2030